hi my name is Olivia lanes and welcome back to Quantum Computing in practice this is episode two Quantum
circuits we're going to be covering several topics in today's lecture but what I want you to walk away knowing are the following three things one what IBM
quantum computers actually are so that you at least have a rough picture in your mind of what you're doing when you send a job to one of those over the
cloud two what kuit is what Primitives are and how we can use them to create create and execute Quantum circuits
we'll also discuss at a high level the different types of IBM Quantum processors available and what distinguishes one from another and three
lastly the typical workflow that we follow to run experiments at scale this includes selecting the best Primitives
for your use case mapping a problem to a Quantum circuit and applying error suppression and mitigation which enable
us to squeeze as much power out of these machines as possible now there's a lot of information here but stick with me
because soon enough we're going to put it all together in the context of some real examples first let's briefly discuss cubits and the actual Quantum
Hardware as an experimentalist I can promise you that it is fascinating and it really helps connect the dots to
visualize what's actually happening when jobs are sent to a quantum computer through the cloud the processors that
we're going to be using are built with superconducting transmon cubits here's what a small IBM quantum processor looks
like now these small squares here are the cubits themselves so there are a total of five on this chip the transmon
itself is a capacitor and it consists of two plates of metal hooked up in paril with a nonlinear inductor called the
Jose injunction but to see the Joseph injunction you actually have to zoom in even more it's created from two
overlapping layers of superconducting metal and where the two pieces overlap and touch is the junction a Jose
Junction is an element that can be used to create an artificial atom with multiple energy levels and we isolate
the bottom two energy levels as our Cubit State the squiggly lines here represent the microwave resonators
basically 2D transmission lines coupled to the Cubit now when we program a gate that essentially equates to choosing a
highly calibrated microwave pulse and the specific frequency amplitude shape and duration of those pulses make the
Cubit do specific things the instructions for the microwave pulse go from your computer to the cloud and
then are read and interpreted by room temperature control Electronics which take those instructions and physically
generate the pulses we call them microwave pulses because they all fit within the microwave frequency bandwidth
which is around 1 GHz after the room temperature control boxes create the pulses they travel through the cables
into the dilution refrigerator and eventually to our Quantum chip the signal goes into the resonators through
a wire Bond on these pads and then it flows down the transmission line into our cubits now I know this all might
have been a little Technical and these details aren't crucial to understand for us going forward but I hope now that you
can all at least picture the physical system that you're all about to interact with so where do these quantum computers
actually exist well IBM has dozens of quantum computers all around the world and we've recently upgraded our Fleet to
contain only 100 plus Cubit processors as I mentioned in the previous lesson some of them are located in an IBM
Quantum data center in Upstate New York those systems are deployed all over the cloud for everyone's use and some of
them are dedicated on premise systems complete with all of the electronics to make them work that support our partners
in the IBM quantum network now let's talk about kcit which is IBM's open-source software development kit
designed to work on quantum computers from now on I'll be referring to this as the kkit SDK there's also the kkit
ecosystem which is a collection of software tutorials and functions that build on or extend the core functionalities of kkit as well as kkit
runtime which is a Quantum Computing service and programming model that allows users to design and efficiently
execute their Quantum workloads by using kcit Primitives and A Primitive is basically a small building block that
you can use to design larger circuits or a job the two Primitives that are most important to us are going to be the
sampler and the estimator which we'll discuss in more depth shortly if you haven't downloaded and installed the
kiss kit SDK yet there is no time like the present kiss kit 1.0 was recently released and it's more performative and
stable than ever before so for those of you that are just getting started you came in at the perfect time for those of
you that are already familiar with kcit you'll need to download and reinstall the newest version we recommend using
pip to install kiss kit and kiss kit runtime and running them through a Jupiter notebook in a web browser of your choice so you're also going to need
to install jupyter notebook or Jupiter lab in case you haven't done that already these tools are all free and you
can get them up and running on your own local machine without any cost make sure to add kiss kit with the visualization
option dependencies so it works with Jupiter and lets you plot things you will also need to set up a virtual python environment and there are
instructions on how to do this on the kit install page linked here once you've become familiar with kkit and you're
ready to run jobs on real quantum computers you'll need to register at quantum.com and create an IBM Quantum
API token and there is also a link for here for that a detailed walkthrough of how to do this follow all the
instructions in our documentation page like I mentioned or you can watch the coding with kkit installation video here
both of which are linked and in the description now we're just about ready to start talking about Quantum
circuits since the point of this course is to teach you the audience how to scale up your jobs to be run at 100 plus
Cubit scale I believe the most constructive way forward is to First consider the overall workflow that we're going to follow and the easiest way to
understand a typical Quantum Computing workflow is through kiss kit patterns kiss kit patterns are a conceptual framework allowing users to run Quantum
workloads by implementing certain steps with modular tooling this allows Quantum Computing task to be performed by
powerful heterogeneous Computing infrastructure these steps can be performed as a service and can
incorporate Resource Management which allows for seamless composability of new capabilities as they are developed here
are the main steps which experienced kcit users will likely already recognize the first step is mapping this step
formalizes how we take a general problem that we're interested in and figure out how to map it in into a quantum computer
in the form of a circuit next we optimize in this step we use the kkit transpiler to route and lay out the
circuit onto an actual physical Quantum Hardware this includes translating the individual Quantum Gates into sequences
of operations that are performed on the hardware as well as optimization in the layout of those Gates next we will
execute kuit runtime Primitives provide the interface to IBM Quantum Hardware that allows transpiled circuit to run
this step also includes using error suppression and mitigation techniques which can largely be abstracted away from the user lastly we postprocess in
this step the data from the quantum processor itself is processed providing the user with useful results on the original problem basically this step
encompasses any further analysis of the data that is acquired now we're ready to discuss the foundation of quantum
programs which are quantum circuits hopefully you're already familiar with Quantum circuits but in case you're not you might want to first check out lesson
three Quantum circuits which is a part of understanding Quantum information and computation linked below we're only
going to be giving a short refresher here now a Quantum circuit is a network of quantum Gates and measurements linked
by wires that represent the cubits Quantum circuits can be read like sheet music from left to right starting at
Time Zero which is all the way on the left virtual cubits meaning cubits that haven't yet been assigned to an actual
physical Cubit on a processor are listed in increasing order from top to bottom once we set up our circuit we can add
gates to it single Cubit Gates like this hadamar gate here affect only the Cubit whose wire it's placed on multiple Cubit
Gates like this cot affect two or more cubits linked by the gate here in this example the state of Cubit one changes
depending on what the state of Cubit zero is in after all of the gates are applied we can perform measurements
which cause the results to be written onto classical registers one particularly important characteristic of
a circuit is its depth the depth of the quantum circuit is the minimum number of layers of quantum Gates executed in
parallel required to complete the computation defined by the circuit to be clear Quantum Gates can be executed in
parallel or in other words at the exact same time whenever they don't have any cubits in common but if two or more
gates act on the same cubits then we can't perform them in parallel we're forced to perform them one after the other because Quantum Gates take time to
implement the depth of a circuit roughly corresponds to the amount of time needed for quantum computers to execute the
circuit so knowing the depth of a circuit is important for knowing that it can be used to run on a particular device or not it also will tell us if it
has a good chance of turning out an accurate result next let's move on to the selection of a Quantum processor IBM
has recently released a whole new Fleet of processors all having over 100 cubits and you can log on to quantum.com to see
which processors you have access to the processors are all named after birds for reasons and the different logos
represent different types of processors so for instance these ones represent Eagle processors and this icon is a
heron the name of the specific processors are also found at the top they're all named after cities but that
doesn't NE necessarily mean that the processor is physically located in that City those are just names Cubit count
eppg and kops are also factors that are all listed we'll go over each of these
cubits now this is pretty self-explanatory cubits is just the number of total cubits available to use on that sole Quantum processor or
qpu EPG stands for the errors per layered gate which measures the average gate process error in a layered chain of
100 cubits basically you want to be as small as possible kops stands for circuit layer operations per second and
it measures how many layers of a Quantum volume circuit which is a virtual circuit a qpu can execute per unit time
the higher the number the faster we can compute this is equivalent to what flops means in classical Computing now these
different metrics may be more or less important depending on the specific application area that you're interested in next let's discuss at a high level
mapping to Quantum circuits the first step is the mapping step which essentially answers the question how do
I translate my problem into a Quantum circuit that can be run on Quantum Hardware now there's no doubt about it
mapping is a hard problem and it's an active area of research sometimes just being able to take a computational
problem and come up with a sequence of quantum Gates that helps solve it is the hardest part there isn't a foolproof
method that guarantees success but there are recommended guidelines and examples of problems that we already know how to
map the first guideline is to let classical computers do whatever work that they are better at themselves tests
that are easy for classical computers probably won't benefit from a quantum computer quantum computers are for problems that are classically hard of
course if this is your very first time using kkit or a quantum computer don't worry about finding a problem that is computationally complex break it down
into smaller problems that you can learn to address before going straight to a utility scale project next translate the
outcomes for your problem that you want to measure or understand into an expectation value problem or a sampling
problem for most types of problems this essentially corresponds to calculating a cost function a cost function is a
problem specific function that defines the problem's goal as something to be minimized or maximized and they can be
used to see how well a trial state or solution is performing with respect to that goal
this notion can be applied to various applications in chemistry machine learning Finance optimization and so on
also keep in mind that the hardware that you're going to be using has a specific topology some cubits aren't connected
and some are and ultimately you'll need to map your problem to a circuit that represents this IBM Quantum processors
use what's called a heavy hex topology which essentially equates to Cubit Connections in a hexagonal lattice which
we'll get into more later in the course for now the most important thing to keep in mind is that this stage requires
practice you need to have a good understanding of not only your problem but also the quantum Hardware
capabilities and we'll go through a specific example and use case later on to see how these can be best
balanced now let's discuss how to optimize a circuit for the hardware that we've selected the overall goal of the
optimization step is to map all of the virtual cubits from our circuit to actual real cubits somewhere on the
topology of the processor the name of the game is to reduce errors as much as possible to do this we first need to
route and lay out our circuit efficiently first thing to keep in mind is that not all cubits are connected as
I've already said some are actually far away from one another on the chip so we need to reduce or eliminate longdistance
interactions whenever possible you can apply a sequence of swap Gates between neighboring cubits to move Cubit
information around but swap gates are costly and prone to errors so there may be better ways of doing this next layout
and routing are iterative processes and they assign a virtual Cubit to your circuit on the physical Cubit on the
hardware you can do this by hand but there are also Tools in kcit which can make recommendations for the physical
Cubit layout based on approximate error rates next we can compose sequences of one cubit Gates acting on the same Cubit
into single Gates and we can also sometimes get rid of unnecessary Gates or combinations of gates for example
some combinations of gates can be reduced to simpler combinations and sometimes combinations of gates even
equate to just a simple identity operator so we can simply eliminate them you can do this automatically using the
kkit transpiler or you can do it manually on a gate bygate basis if you have a good reason to do so and you want
more control once we've improved the circuit layout routing and gate counts either by hand or by using the kuit transpiler we
usually want to visualize our circuit to make sure that the timing of all the gates makes sense there is an argument that you can flag in the transpiler to
visualize the timeline of your circuit and make sure that everything is lined up the way that you would expect now let's talk about error
suppression error suppression refers to various techniques that transform a C during compilation to minimize errors
it's different from error mitigation which takes place after the circuit has already been run and we'll come to that shortly the two most common forms of
error suppression that we take advantage of are dynamical decoupling and poly twirling there is going to be some
technical details here but you can always refer back to this later so the first dynamical decoupling is used to
effectively cancel out some of the noise affecting the Cubit by applying a series of gates that together amount to the
identity operation like XX sequences and whose net effect is to approximately cancel out the noise channels affecting
the cubid poly twirling is a way of inserting random gates to simplify the average noise the randomness helps
prevent the effects from different errors from building up as fast and also makes the noise easier to characterize
now this method also forms the basis of an error mitigation technique and we're going to be discussing that later
again there's a lot of information here and don't worry if it doesn't all SN in immediately luckily a lot of this can be done automatically using the kcit
transpiler transpilation can be tricky though but the transpilation is such a crucial step to achieve utility at scale
that it requires a lot of trial and error in order to be mastered and obtained the best results now I want to take a brief
interlude to discuss the kiskat transpiler and its capabilities a bit more I'll do this at a very high level and we'll get into the details and see
some examples later on in general transpilation is the process of rewriting a given input circuit to match
the topology and specific Quantum device and optimize the circuit for execution and resilience against noise it also
rewrites a given circuit into the basis Gates of that specific Quantum processor you have selected to use kkit has four
built-in transpilation pipelines and unless you're already familiar with Quantum circuit optimization I definitely recommend using one of those
built-in pipelines by default the transpiler includes these six steps initialization
layout routing translation optimization and scheduling now initialization refers to
any initial pass that is required before we start embedding the circuit onto the back end this typically involves
unrolling custom instructions and converting the circuit into just one and two Cubit Gates the layout stage applies
a layout mapping the virtual cubits in the circuit to the physical cubits on a back end routing runs after a layout has
been applied and injects Gates such as swap Gates into the original circuit to make it compatible with the backend's
connectivity the fourth stage is translation in this stage the gates in the circuit are translated to the Target
backends basis set next is optimization this stage runs the main optimization
Loop repeatedly until a condition such as reaching a certain Target depth is met we have four different optimization
levels that we are able to choose from last is scheduling this stage is for any hardware aware scheduling passes at a
high level scheduling can be thought of as inserting delays into the circuit to account for any idle time on the cubits
between the execution of instructions so like I said there are four optimization levels ranging from 0 to three where
higher optimization levels take more time and computational effort but you might end up with a better circuit
optimization level zero is intended for device characterization experiments and as such only Maps the input circuit to
the constraints of the target backend it doesn't perform any optimization optimization level three
spends the most effort to optimize the circuit however as many of the optimization techniques in the
transpiler are based on heris sixs spending more computational effort doesn't always result in an improvement
in the quality of the output circuit if this is of further interest please check out the transpiler pages in the kisc
documentation linked below now we are ready to discuss the actual execution of a Quantum circuit
the kcit runtime Primitives provide an interface to IBM Quantum hardware and they also abstract away error
suppression and mitigation from the user the sampler primitive Returns the Quasi probability distribution or counts
representing the likelihood of measuring certain bit strings zeros and ones the estimator primitive returns expectation
values of observables corresponding to physical quantities so in a little bit more detail the sampler runs the circuit
multiple times on a Quantum device performing measurements on each run and constructing the probability
distribution from recovering those bit strings the more runs or shots it performs the more accurate the results
will be but this requires more time and the Quantum Resources required to run that specifically it calculates the
probability of obtaining each possible standard basis state by measuring the state prepared by the circuit kiskis
estimator uses a complex algebraic process to estimate the expectation value on a real Quantum device by
breaking down the observable into a combination of other observables that have known igen bases and running under
the hood of The Primitives are the techniques called error mitigation error mitigation is an umbrella term for all of this and it
basically refers to the techniques that allow us to reduce circuit Errors By modeling the device noise at the time of
execution typically this results in Quantum pre-processing overhead related to the model training and classical
post-processing overhead to mitigate errors in the Raw results by using a generated model but in exchange for this
overhead we're able to get much more accurate results there are multiple techniques that we can Implement for
error mitigation and we're going to go over three of them in more detail be aware however that this is an area of
active research so new techniques will likely be invented and older ones will continue to be improved upon the
resilience level increases the cost or in other words the time it takes to run your job we already said that at
resilience level zero the transpiler doesn't really do anything to your circuit but starting at resilience level one it introduces a method called twirled
readout error Extinction or we call it T-Rex for short twirled readout error Extinction uses poly twirling to
mitigate noise which is something that we've already touched upon it's a very general and effective technique that
intuitively speaking makes the noise less irregular and easier to deal with starting at resilience level two we
introduce zero noise extrapolation or zne for short this is a popular technique that we've recently had a lot
of success with the idea behind Zen might be a bit surprising we actually add additional
noise on top of what's already there but what this does is it allows us to extrapolate in the reverse direction to
predict what the results would look like if there was less noise this can be done in several specific ways for instance we
can stretch out the gates to make them longer and thus more prone to error or we can run more gates that ultimately
result in an identity operation so the circuit doesn't actually functionally change but we purposefully sample more
noise you do have to do this for every circuit and every expectation value that you want to keep track of though so you
can see how it can end up being very expensive in terms of the time required one specific type of z& is called
probabalistic error amplification paa for short once we've learned a noise model for a gate paa works by sampling
errors from that noise model and deliberately injecting them into the circuit like I mentioned lots of new
techniques are continuing to be developed and will hopefully be implemented as we see more and more come into play there's just one final form of
error mitigation that I want to discuss called probabilistic error cancellation instead of being at the third resilience
level PE is a special capability that you have to manually turn on and kissk because the computational resources
needed for it don't scale very well compared to the other air mitigation techniques that we've discussed You
Begin by learning about the noise that's affecting your circuit by running noise learning or noise characterization
circuits for each unique layer of two Cubit Gates that are in your circuit these results let you describe the noise
in terms of poly operators once you know these noise terms you can modify your circuits so
that they effectively have the opposite PES built in to cancel these noise channels in some ways this process is
similar to that of noise cancelling headphones however this way of undoing the noise is very costly with a time to
run that grows exponentially quickly in the number of gates so it may not be the best choice for a very large circuit we
have now reached the final stage postprocessing in the end if you've done a good job and employed proper error
mitigation techniques you might see your final answer shift like like in this figure here an unmitigated distribution
shown in purple is quite far from the true expected value shown here by this line however once we apply our error
mitigation we obtain a mitigated distribution shown here in blue which Peaks much closer to the True Value now
this all comes at a cost and here we can see that the variance or the width of the distribution is increased which
isn't generally what you want but everything comes at a cost luckily we can account for this by running more
shots which causes the distribution to shrink back to an acceptable level of uncertainty so that's about it for this
lesson for next time we're going to take all of these steps and put them together and work through an area and an example
of actual application interest there's a few things that I can recommend that we do until then if you haven't yet make
sure that you download and set up kuit 1.0 you can also check out the Associated lesson for this chapter and
the previous episode in the IBM Quantum learning platform and lastly if you have any interest in digging in more and
learning more about error mitigation techniques check out one of the numerous sources that I've linked below until then we'll see you next time
[Music]